so donald trump's niece mary trump is
again weighing in on what she believes
is the growing fear in her uncle donald
trump uh of the walls closing in around
him and criminality enveloping him and
possibly leading to charges and we're
going to look at a clip of her appearing
on i believe it's msnbc to talk about
this and i do find it interesting but at
the same time and if i'm wrong please
tell me
i appreciate the perspective
of someone from trump's family and when
she first emerged from the shadows
it was particularly interesting but now
i'm actually wondering
what mary trump really knows about
what's going on right now with donald
trump because as far as i know she has
no contact with him or that side of the
family whatsoever so let's take a listen
this is interesting and it may well be
what donald trump is feeling but it may
be just as speculative as what i can
deduce trump might be feeling from his
posts on truth social more than any
personal knowledge let's take a look
joining me now is donald trump's niece
mary trump she's the author of too much
and never enough mary good morning
always good to see you uh listen by your
training you are a psychologist and you
also know someone you are someone who
knows trump very well what do you think
is going through his mind right now
because there's an incredibly
getting even larger amount of damning
testimony that's coming out and
noticeably he did not attack pat
cipolloni before sipoloni testified
before the 1-6 committee
yeah good morning katie i i think neil
carriel summed it up quite nicely i you
know uh to say that donald is terrified
is accurate and also an understatement
um i think this might be the first time
in his entire life
that even he can't deny the walls may
indeed be closing in uh the amount of
evidence that that we've seen coming out
at these committee hearings is
overwhelming
but
even more troubling for him is the
witnesses now coming forward so i mean
like yeah it's interesting
but it has a sort of like daytime tv
feel thing to it rather than real
journalism because mary trump has no
contact with trump and she hasn't for a
long time
and let's imagine she's right about
trump's fears and state of mind right
now which she may well be
it's possible to come to that same
conclusion from what's available
publicly in fact i have come to the same
conclusion so that that's one piece of
it and the continued mary trump
interviews on the other hand you know
when it comes to accountability
accountability has to be real it can't
just be discussed it can't just be well
accountability is all these people made
you look really guilty during their
testimony okay that's fine but it's got
to lead to something and maybe if trump
is held accountable at some point
we can sort of define a line that can't
be crossed and it would be quite a low
bar but if we can't even do that then
this is just going to happen again and
we've talked before about how right now
because there have been no real
consequences for donald trump to
everything that he did and i won't give
you the full list because i'm sure at
this point you're sick of hearing it
it's not evident that you can't cross
the lines we're not really a democracy
in the sense of checks and balances one
person one vote etc
if you can have checks and balances that
don't actually keep anyone in check and
balanced against their uh
fascistic tendencies
and we don't know what's taking so long
now to some degree it takes a while to
build cases and if there are indictments
from doj it may take some time
but for now it is not clear that we even
have an infrastructure willing and able
to assign consequences and repercussions
for what has taken place so interesting
to hear from mary trump i don't really
know that at this point she really knows
any more than any of us do because of
how long she hasn't been in touch with
donald trump newsmax host greg kelly has
an idea for unifying the country
just pardon all the january 6 trump riot
defenders joe biden could really bring
everybody together
if he just said hey you know what
we're going to let you all go we're
going to pardon all of you now how that
would unite the country i don't know but
let's listen to what greg kelly had to
say political opponents political
enemies
in jail you know if he wanted to unify
this country on january 21st after he
made that solemn pledge his whole soul
was in it to unify us
he could have gone to that jail and made
arrangements for them to be let go
how would that even unify the country
like most of the country
it's shocking that the country's ever
really united on anything but most of
the country is already united that the
riots were bad
it was trumpists who did it the
perpetrators should be prosecuted so how
would saying we're going to let all you
guys go
how would that unite the country it
seems it would be an incredibly dumb
thing to do maybe he meant instead of
unifying this is how to capitulate to
the extreme right just let all of them
go and meanwhile remember that they
preach personal responsibility in all of
it they say we have to be responsible
for our actions we have to take
seriously when we make a decision we
have ultimate agency we're the ultimate
agents of our lives and sometimes those
actions come with consequences but
actually the president should just let
all of us go what and and the other kind
of layer to this that's weird and i
don't expect a host on newsmax to really
understand this or take it seriously
anyway is
if they did nothing wrong as is another
narrative
then why would they need to be pardoned
if they didn't do anything wrong they'll
just be found not guilty
they will never stop claiming
that the other side needs to do
something what about not rioting what
about that as a way to stay out of
trouble don't riot to begin with and
then you wouldn't have this problem in
the from the get-go they
every principal that they claim to
espouse goes in the
third element of the bathroom the toilet
as soon as it's inconvenient and now
it's personal responsibility well all of
a sudden it's up to biden it's up for
whoever to give them these get out quite
literally get out of jail free cards not
gonna happen and it actually wouldn't
unify the country it would do the
opposite because most of the country
shockingly actually thinks these rioters
did do something wrong and they need to
be held accountable
this is now completely beyond parody
my pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
i know you're going to say david but you
did this story last year i know
mike lindell also known as mike pillow
or just pillow
has new
very very big not just very big but very
very big
cyber evidence
cyber evidence
that is going to blow the roof off
of the 2020 election now we're only what
three and a half months from the 2022
election but he's still working on 2020.
listen to this and at this point does
anyone believe this i mean the crowds at
trump rallies cheer
when he says this stuff but do they even
believe it i got news this morning that
there was a
very
big big big
big everybody pieces of evidence cyber
evidence
from the 2020 election
that we didn't even know before that now
we have it's it's
i'm just like
so excited validated
validated uh multiple sources and we
also
found from another source a completely
different cyber guy um
he seems almost bored by his own
blockbuster news he sounds kind of like
he's over it we found uh
more evidence from the
the uh mesa
data which we have right up here in
frank's speech so all you horrible
journalists out there that are watching
tonight uh you might want to take a look
there
and uh
look at what i'm talking about and
get your cyber guys ready there's more
to come and uh and it's very readable
and understandable a sniffing disheveled
uncomfortable looking mike pillow
making declarations that even his
co-host seems to be pretty damn
skeptical of now would it be shocking to
you
to find out that all of this new
evidence comes from nest thermostats
that would be a big shock but apparently
nest thermostats are the new nexus of
cyber criminality i'm genuinely curious
about how long this is going to go
because we're almost at the 2022
midterms could pillow keep going with
this beyond the 2022 midterms what about
2024. like there's no way that after 24
he would say we're going to go back and
re-reinstate trump from the 2020
election right like that that seems
beyond even
pillows ability to take himself
seriously i don't know the answer but
he's still invited to the trump rallies
he still speaks there and at some point
the question has to become
he keeps if he keeps repeating it
is it because people keep believing it
and thinking that this guy knows
something when he knows nothing at all
maybe like with trump it's more about
the followers than the person saying the
stuff strange
bizarre
unusual and also comical quite frankly
but the the perfect touch here
is that he just seems bored he's like i
have very very big evidence it's coming
out soon
this is like the biggest most exciting
thing
and we're gonna tell you it's from uh
you know it's
from arizona and it's gonna just blow
everything up it's gonna overturn the
election he he couldn't be more bored
with his own so-called data all right
the question i have is how long will
this go on will it go on beyond 2022
will it get all the way to 2024 when
will pillow end this madness find me on
twitter at dpakman and let me know
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is different from
other shows at least from some other
shows we depend on the support of our
audience for our operation
meaning you can sign up at
joinpacman.com and become a member and
get the bonus show oh the bonus show
yeah
and the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show and all of it and
you can do it at a discount with the
coupon code big voting 22.
let's hear from some people in the
audience at davidpakman.com
discord
and
you can
discord is free i'm not selling you
anything other than a good time and we
will hear from some people because if
you weren't here it would be really
weird let's start with ricky from
charlotte ricky welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey david i wanted to ask you about two
potential future scenarios that
uh i think are somewhat plausible and
could give the left some hope if they do
happen i just want to see how likely you
thought they were okay um the first one
being around the supreme court i see
that it seems now the the court is
completely politicized like all the
retirements will be
um
super politicized by all the justices
going forward but i do wonder if we
could hope that roberts is not as crazy
as like the republican as like you know
the way the republicans are now and he's
and and it would be conceivable that at
some point he could retire when there is
a democrat in office i don't see that
happening with like alito or thomas or
any of the crazy ones but roberts is
someone that i'm holding hope on do you
think that could happen i mean
sure but he's only 67 so you know if
history is an indicator it's not
happening anytime soon it's not
happening soon enough that there's
really any reason to speculate now
because it could be decades away
um
yeah i mean
67 is
i mean you know maybe it could be like
10 years from now i mean you know if
he's been on the court for like uh 20
years at this point
i don't i think i saw like the average
justice serves like around 20 years or
something like that so okay
i mean listen there's nothing we can do
about it it can't be part of any kind of
strategy i guess is my point because we
don't know when it would happen anyway
yeah but
i i just don't see that it would happen
with anyone else uh and if it happened
with him i feel like that would you know
that could
uh vote well for us but okay the second
one i just want to ask about really
quick um
if
the
you know trump and desantis or other
republicans go ahead in the primary if
trump loses
i feel like he will do another it was
rigged against me and
um
you know the establishment of stealing
from me he's like stop the steel bs and
like cause the republican rnc like the
same headaches that he's called like the
whole country and stuff um do you see
that happening do you think if that did
happen would he potentially run as a
third party no i think i mean maybe but
listen so here's the deal trump would
never win as a third party and of course
if trump fights for the republican
nomination and loses he will say that it
was rigged and stolen from him by the
rhinos but then that'll be it you know
he'll be like almost 80 and he's not
going to run at age 84 and that that'll
kind of it'll be it so yes it'll be
annoying and he'll do it but then then
we'll be rid of trump
do you think that would damage
the uh whoever the nominee is in that
point like the republicans the general
if he ran as a third party candidate no
no if if he lost in like one attack the
primary yeah exactly uh no probably not
oh dang
okay man i was hoping for i think what
would hurt republicans is just a really
long and
um
contentious primary i think that that
would be bad for republicans
yeah i because i remember last time
before the primary ted cruz actually
seemed like a politician that could win
an election and after trump annihilated
him i don't see him ever like winning
nash i mean never say never but he seems
like super weak now so yeah anyways
thank you david all right ricky from
charlotte thank you so much uh very very
much appreciate that
uh let's see what else we have going on
here because we are taking calls
let's go next to
uh chang from taiwan chang welcome
uh hello can you hear me just just
barely barely barely uh i'll try to
speak up uh
okay
what i wanted to talk about today was
less of a question what kind of just
exasperation but
the republicans and the logic they apply
to gun regulation is just ridiculous
because they never seem to apply it to
just about
anything else imagine if the logic that
they applied to guns was applied to
abortions you know if people want this
if they're determined to get this
they're going to get it somehow
but they don't seem to be able to see
how their own logic can apply to other
situations scenarios yes the issue with
that particular example is that it can
also be reversed on the left by saying
hey if your argument is that by banning
abortions you don't actually stop them
then why do you think banning guns will
work right so that one can be turned
around on anybody
true but for the left that would be more
the case that even if it's not a 100
prevention it's still a decrease which
is what you actually want
well they could say that about abortion
they could say yes some people will go
and have an unsafe home abortion but it
will be a decrease i mean they can
literally use the exact same phraseology
you are right from that
it's it's just very frustrating
especially it's frustrating i don't deny
that there is a double standard stuff
recently as well
right
right
well it's a good point although i think
that they always have a counterpoint to
it
yeah and unfortunately they didn't
necessarily need that cancer point to be
consistent no if they don't i mean the
right doesn't care about consistency
unfortunately yeah
uh thanks for taking my call all right
chang thank you very much uh
very soft-spoken with a with a quiet
connection made it a little difficult
but we did it we really did
let's go next to
how about
stevie from asheville north carolina
stevie welcome
hey david uh thanks for having me on my
pleasure
i just had a question a little bit of a
specific question today or uh that's i
guess the theme is supreme court but um
so in the idea of or in counseling
there's this concept of duty to protect
whereas a client has confidentiality
from their therapist in most cases
except for a few specific ones and just
like to list one for instance uh child
abuse if a client were to disclose to a
therapist that they're abusing their
child then duty to warn dirty to protect
the counselor would have to inform the
law of course my question is in the wake
of some of this in the wake of the
supreme court decision in which some
states are going to ban abortion i'm
curious if some states are going to say
oh a fetus that is a child if if a
client were to say they're seeking an
abortion outside of the state does would
that fall under child abuse and would
the counselor have a duty to protect for
um an unborn child
so they would absolutely argue that i
think the question would be
whether local police could really do
anything about it because let's imagine
a different example i guess
imagine that a client disclosed to a
client in texas disclosed to their
therapist i'm planning to kill someone
in amsterdam or something like that okay
so the therapist can go and they can
call texas police and texas police maybe
could ask some questions but they really
probably can't do anything the the crime
is supposedly going to happen in
amsterdam and then if you call amsterdam
police and say this person might be
doing this thing they would say okay
thanks for letting us know if they come
to amsterdam
then we will be aware of it but there's
nothing they can do until the person is
there so in the in thinking about the
instance of a oh
abortions banned in texas you tell your
therapist i'm going to go to neighboring
wherever to get
uh an abortion i don't think texas
police can really do anything about it
because it's not a crime in that other
state and they're not planning to do it
in texas yeah i i think that they will
make the argument but i don't think it
will be very effective at doing anything
right i think that it all comes back to
trying to enforce abortion laws like
this in general is just kind of silly
yes it is it absolutely is and uh there
are going to be all sorts of absurd
situations like this for sure but we'll
have to deal with them as they come up
right okay well that that's just the
thought i've been having lately uh thank
you for having me on all right stevie
from asheville very much appreciate it
nice connection got right to the
question
hard to beat that
let's go next to dylan from
massachusetts dylan welcome
hey david how's it going it's going well
it's good to hear um so if biden were to
by executive order set up abortion
clinics on federal land
in states that have banned abortion do
you think that there's anything that
those states can do to stop those
clinics from functioning you know i i'm
sure that there are things they can try
to do with new arguments that we've not
heard used before
but it would be sort of like a va
hospital in a sense right where
when in fact i remember a story from
growing up in massachusetts where at a
va hospital there was like a nurse that
killed a bunch of patients by
deliberately giving them too much of the
wrong medication and it was subject to
the death penalty even though
massachusetts didn't have it because it
happened in a federal facility and i
believe that along the same lines if
federal facilities wanted to offer
abortion services even in states that
have banned it i think it would be very
difficult for the state to supersede or
come in and do anything about it i mean
it would have to be tested and there
would be a test but it sounds like it
would be pretty solid
yeah because i've heard arguments um
from people who say that that's a bad
idea for biden to do that by executive
order like for example if a state were
to arrest
like someone
like a doctor going on site before or
after they leave the federal land yep
for having committed the crime of
uh doing an abortion procedure on
federal land like that would get very
dicey that would get extremely dicey
because it's not like a uh it's not like
an embassy right a va hospital a federal
hospital it's not like an embassy where
literally no rules apply
um but yeah i mean it's it's really a
complicated legal question
yeah if you have if you could snap your
fingers and compel joe biden to set up
these va abortion clinics on federal
land
would you or or would you not
compel him to do that uh i'd have to
think about it i would really have to
think about it i mean the ideal thing
would be to codify roe v wade but that's
not up to biden that's up to democrats
in the senate they don't have the votes
i would want to know more about it
before i took a really strong position
on it
i i i'm of the same opinion yeah do do
you think if um democrats get the votes
after
you know by some miracle this midterm
elections uh do you think that the
supreme court would allow
roe to be codified into law i
from what i've read it would be very
difficult for the supreme court to stop
it
yeah
all right well thanks for taking my call
david all right dylan from massachusetts
very much appreciate the call
let's go next to andrew from missouri
welcome andrew
yes hello hi can you hear me yes i can
excellent um so i am actually from the
ozarks in southwest missouri and i have
seen uh it's it's alarming to me uh in
the last year and well two years really
how many younger people have kind of
bought into the trumpest uh talking
points and just trumpism in general
auntie biden um
to the point that it
it's one of those things where i worry
that we're not going to see this pass as
the older generation passes that would
that we're going to have to deal with
this for even longer and i'm just
wondering there's a couple of points to
this uh
how do we combat this brainwashing of
the younger generations and like do
these do these hearings help with that
or are they gonna really or are they
just gonna be ignored by people who are
already trenched and then
with that do democrats need to start
playing the unfortunately playing the
political theater game just to
just to get their their base
riled up to combat
trumpism
overall so i don't think that young
people are necessarily watching the
january 6th hearings in any
significantly large number so i wouldn't
count on that i actually have a
different perspective which is although
there are these young right-wing
movements like turning point usa
targeting people on college campuses
i actually think that the young folks
are the ones that have been least
brainwashed and the ones that were sort
of counting on so i don't see them as
the biggest problem to solve the you
know the older facebook conspiracy folks
seem like really the the problem
um but of course we want to make sure
that we're equipping young people with
tools so that they never become
indoctrinated in the first place
including critical thinking skills media
literacy etc
yeah yeah and it's it's it's one of
those
those things where are we
i don't know it feels like
the right has such a stranglehold on
controlling the narrative that
that i don't know how we can combat that
effectively that because they've been at
it for so long
i agree with you and i've talked about
all of the things that need to happen
it's the ones i already mentioned here
also the left needs to be as good and as
committed as the right to funding groups
that are working to grow the movement
the right just throws money at it they
don't care they won't stop and it's part
of why they succeed
yeah yeah hey real quick andrew before
you go can you name four countries that
start with the letter g out of curiosity
uh four countries start with the letter
g yeah uh
we got georgia germany ghana and
[Music]
that's embarrassing well we i would have
accepted greece or guatemala greece
greece oh thank you yeah there we go all
right andrew thank you for the call i
appreciate it
thank you very much you have a good one
all right you too all right guys let's
take a very quick break we're taking
more calls so don't hang up if you're
holding on we're going right back to the
phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right
let's hear from a few more people we
take calls via discord on the friday
show davidpakman.com
discord it's completely free completely
free
let's go to uh oh i don't know let's go
to brody from dallas brody what's going
on
hey david i hope you're doing well um
i actually have a bone to pick with you
i have to say all right
when you when you call in you do these
beautiful calls sometimes sort of
esoteric topics but you're respectful
and you're kind and all these things but
then it seems like you're plaguing our
discord and subreddit with kind of
strange attacks on me and on the show is
that are there two brodies so to speak
i don't think there are two brodies i
think the latest thing that might have
plagued your reddit was uh the
show about the show
what was that
that was the david pakman show show
oh my god
show about the show that encourages
people to subscribe well that sounds
good i don't know
yeah every show we talk about the
benefits of membership and making sure
that they support your show
hard to be against that well what's on
your mind today brody
um i was actually thinking about a
interview i heard um with ezra client a
while back talking about if we are
entering an era of post-persuasion
politics
meaning that um so many people seem to
be subject to asymmetrical polarization
or a stronger level of polarization
and
i wanted to know in your observation
because you've been in the game for a
long time um do you see the era of
politics that we are in now in terms of
retail politics electoral politics
do you see us moving or are we already
in an area where it's all about
registering cultivating and turning out
a base or do you see that there is still
room for persuasion
uh on a broader level i think it's
mostly the former and there is some of
the latter i mean i think you're
starting to get these smaller and
smaller you you know one of the genius
things that trump did and i'm not even
saying that he did it on purpose it just
happened is that he reached people
who had not been paying attention to
politics in any real way so they didn't
even realize that they were being lied
to that trump's campaign promises were
impossible that they were being
propagandized and on and on and on so
what was genius about it was they
completely uncritically were just like
oh trump oh yeah i'm voting for trump
and they were insulated from any kind of
critical thought and that's why when the
access hollywood tape came out it didn't
make a difference and all these
different things
increasingly
to win
you have to find those groups of people
that have not yet become asymmetrically
rattle radicalized the way that you're
pointing out or just asymmetrically
sort of devoted to one side or the other
and trump trump was able to do that so i
think that it's a it's an important
observation and it's an accurate one
and just as a quick follow-up to that do
you think that the current
infrastructure and the current messaging
that the broader democratic party and
candidates have is capable of fulfilling
the uh
the mission there i guess that you
outlined in terms of being able to find
folks that are able to be persuaded and
create a media ecosystem that promotes
that hasn't i mean not so far so far
they've failed on two fronts one they've
failed to properly fund the effort to
create that ecosystem and number two
they've failed to identify
a contingent of the half of the country
that doesn't vote that could be
sort of assembled as a voting block and
activated so so far they've not proven
they can do it
awesome well i appreciate you taking my
call and i will try and behave a little
bit better in your discord yeah let's
keep it clean on there please
yes sir okay
brody from dallas great to hear from him
uh why don't we go next to i hope i
pronounced this correctly is it kumi
from missouri
kumay
komi
you're muted comey you have to unmute
yourself i've unmuted you but unless
there is.com i was coming sorry kame
welcome to the program
i've come to colin about
yesterday's uh january 6 committee
findings
just cut out
oh i cut out you
all right go ahead what see if you can
get the question in
okay so according to the sixth committee
the turner diaries was used in the
planning of the assault on the capital
if you don't know it's the neo-nazi
manifesto used by the far right in many
cases of terrorism like oklahoma city
[Music]
and do you think there's a possibility
that they could cause like
eventual
rise at the far right or
set off in the future
that what would cause that the turner
diaries
no just casual insertion of white
supremacist talking points
oh uh you know i don't expect uh no i
don't i i don't think so i don't that's
not a major can i have many many
different concerns but i can't say that
that's one of them
i mean you have tucker carlson that fox
news uh pulling the strings and
inserting the great replacement
yeah no that's true i mean i guess
i guess it depends on whether you
consider all of these things part of the
same movement or not but uh i mean yeah
listen maybe i guess i just don't think
about things in those terms
if people like tucker and others start
and they have been sort of weaponizing
these ideas they're putting their own
spin on them and making them sort of
something new and of themselves even
though it's linked to something else so
uh yeah i mean i guess to some degree
but i don't necessarily see things as so
kind of siloed in black and white
i see
uh here in missouri
we're dealing we have to deal with a
barrage of anti-trans laws
yes
hypocritically one of them was found out
to be a child molester
one of the people pushing the laws
uh yeah oh that's not surprising that's
old hat that that's that's it would be
surprising if that wasn't the case
true every conservative accusation has a
confession at this point it is it's
incredible i mean i haven't heard of the
specific one but we've seen that all
over the country
and also the groomer accusations are
getting pretty violent like proud boys
attacking uh drag queen story hours and
some people bringing long arms to disney
world
it's an insane insane world out there
it's crazy
it is
all right well thank you for the call i
really appreciate it
you're welcome all right there we go
always great to hear from people from
missouri very very important
let's go next to wasif from dhaka
welcome
hello it's been a while thank you for
you know
picking me protocol i guess pleasure yes
from bangladesh
yes yes okay so my question is you know
more or less related to you know
the
gun topic i guess you could say the gun
control issue what you know whatever you
may call it sure uh this is what i think
you know like i have heard this phrase
you know
mainly among you know these zionist
americans i mean even you know ben
shapiro went to you know let's say
what's his name but pierce morgan pierce
morgan's uh tv show right and he
basically you know stated at this point
so therefore his point was basically
like this that you know our ancestors in
you know eastern europe are in ashes
because they didn't have guns to protect
that's why we need you know less gun
restrictions basically
yeah i've addressed that before it's
crazy i have addressed it yeah um
so uh yeah i mean listen uh ben
shapiro's jewish i'm jewish he has
fallen for this talking point that if
the jews had had guns the holocaust
wouldn't have happened historians have
looked at the claim
um it's just the the facts aren't true
and the conclusion isn't true
guns were not initially even banned uh i
mean there's so many reasons why it's
historically inaccurate but i can assure
you
that handguns and rifles would not have
prevented the holocaust
obviously i'm just i'm asking you
because you know i know you're jewish
right this is what that's why you know i
could have asked this question to you
know let's say anyone else
uh
doing you know similar work as you like
you know leftist podcast right
but i chose you specifically to ask this
question because i knew you know your
background was jewish okay thank you for
taking my call well my answer has
nothing to do the whole i think the
important thing is my answer is just
based on what historians have written
about it um and me being jewish doesn't
doesn't change that uh okay well thank
you for the call i uh i really
appreciate it
all right there goes wasif great to hear
from him
why don't we go next to kank from
arkansas am i pronouncing that correctly
it's kank
oh yes yes you are definitely well
welcome
welcome i'm a big fan of yours i've been
a big fan of yours for like 20 years
it's amazing i'm even talking to you i'm
kind of overwhelmed thank you well
you're doing great so far okay thank you
so much um
i'm a progressive in arkansas which you
know arkansas is super maga super
conservative but that has nothing to do
with my question but basically do you
think you'll ever get a spot in any of
the mainstream news organizations like
cnn msnbc et cetera
oh i don't i mean i'm not even looking
for that i don't know probably not i
don't i don't think so i can't imagine
they'd be interested in me but i i like
working for myself and setting my own
schedule and taking vacation when i want
and not having you know 12 bosses and
editors and stuff like that so i'm i'm
not even looking for that
well what if there was like do you
remember current tv with keith olbermann
and tyt yes
if there's ever a progressive station
like in the mainstream in the united
states would you ever consider having a
slot like you're keeping your business
the way it is you know david pakman
channel but also having your own
hour 30 minute long tv show on some sort
of mainstream network sure i mean listen
i i consider all proposals
so certainly if someone brings me a
proposal i would consider it
all right great because i would love to
see you on tv i think you're a great
influence to the american political
sphere and i wish you the best of luck
in
everything you have going in the future
and i wish to see you debate ben shapiro
or stephen crowder or any of those
stupid right wingers eventually in the
future well thank you and remember we
are on satellite tv every night on
directv and dish network on free speech
tv
yeah i i watch you on free speech tv
very much oh nice thank you yeah but
thank you for taking my call i really
appreciate it all right thank you
there's kank from arkansas very very
powerful declaration about television
let's go next to atreides from boston a
treaties from boston
uh
what are you like a dune fan
uh yes i am very much i say this as i'm
sitting right next to my doing poster
all right well don't sit too close you
can hear me all right i can hear you
fine
uh excellent okay so i have a couple of
questions um
so
bernie in 2016 and 2020 ran and you know
almost got the nomination but wasn't
able to secure it
but in doing that he was able to sort of
renew a progressive movement within the
country and within the democratic party
um and somewhat similar in my home state
of massachusetts uh ranked choice voting
was on the ballot back in 2020 and um
wasn't able to get past but now
countless more people that i talk to and
that i've interacted with and that i see
now know about rcv and support it um
i
maybe will might seem a bit of an
optimist but do you think that there's
merit in the byproduct of a loss that
eventually leads to some sort of victory
or do you think those are more just
self-contained victories with like
limited success no sometimes that is the
case i mean it's very hard in any
particular situation to say could this
defeat actually be what eventually
rockets us to a victory but in business
that's extraordinarily common where a
business will have an initial product or
service which fails and that allows them
to realize oh there's actually this
completely different way to do it
there's this better idea and were it not
for the failure if the initial failure
had instead been a modest success they
would have never come across the major
success and the same thing can happen
it's just hard in any particular case to
say okay does the failure of rank choice
mean that eventually it will be an even
bigger success it's so hard to say but
conceptually that's not an infrequent
occurrence something fails it lets you
reset and figure out the best way or the
right way or whatever and then you have
an even bigger success than you
otherwise would have had
great yeah no i definitely definitely
agree with you um new coke for example
um yeah so what was the thing about that
i've actually read about that so coke
introduced was new coke the one that was
clear or it was just the new flavor
no that's crystal pepsi new coke was
like they sort of changed
i might be getting this a little wrong
but new coke they like changed the
recipe and tried to like re-brand coke
this was during like the cola wars in
the 80s and uh it backfired badly so
they brought back coke classic and go
classic did much much better than um
than new coke right yep i've read
extensively although it was years ago
about that that area it's actually
fascinating even as a non-soda drinker
generally speaking like myself
all right
um i did have a a follow-up question
sure uh so
as we know biden is he's not very
popular right now i believe that recent
poll said that 71 of americans uh don't
want him to seek reelection which isn't
doesn't spell great for the democrats in
2024 uh and i've heard
whispers and murmurs that gavin newsom
would be in his uh
in his absence if he doesn't seek
re-election something that i've
i'm not i don't really have much to back
this up it's more of just a hypothesis
but i'm worried that the dnc would sort
of panic and they'd find a moderate
democrat or somebody who's maybe not so
moderate um like tulsi gabbard for
example who
if you see she has
no i i was worried they were just going
to just throw her to the front yeah
because chelsea's not even a democrat at
this point if the dnc
certainly might anoint someone they
might say we're anointing kamala in joe
biden's absence on the ticket or
who whoever but they're not going to go
to tulsi tulsi is essentially a
republican she spoke at cpac you know
yeah she's [ __ ] cpa it's crazy now
that don't worry about that that's not
gonna happen
okay yeah uh just like a
just a general hypothesis i said yeah
but uh yeah thank you for taking my call
my pleasure great to hear from you there
goes atreides from boston
great to speak to people that does it
for today
but we will take calls again
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
let's uh check out the mailbag
you can email info at davidpakman.com if
you have any questions comments concerns
trolling that you want to do info
davidpakman.com is the place let's uh
jump right into it vera from finland
says pro-lifer's next move very exciting
hey david i for one am excited for the
next step for the pro-life movement and
i have a proposal make organ donation
mandatory after all lots of people die
every year because they don't get an
organ transplant that they need so what
is more pro-life than preventing those
deaths honestly i think this should have
been their first step since it's much
less radical than forcing people to give
birth corpses don't need organs after
all and i'm sure an all-powerful god can
just give you new ones if the afterlife
exists so chop chop pro-lifers your work
is not done
unless of course i'm misunderstanding
the movement says vera and it's not
actually about preserving life at all
but that would mean they're lying
douchebags and lying as a sin so i'm
sure that can't be it yet this is a good
this is a good point and the email is
tongue-in-cheek but we've talked about
this before in the context of
there aren't even things we force people
to do in death
so how is it we can force them to do it
medically
in life that's a contrast that seems
like a
jarring double standard and vera
correctly points it out and the other
double standard is
if they can't claim to care about
children
then
they should be funding
uh pre-k
head start paid paternity leave paid
maternity leave all of these different
things increasing and making permanent
the child tax credits the larger all of
these things and they don't
why because it's not really about that
it never was
and uh in unfortunately in reality their
next move isn't going to be to properly
fund maternal care their next move isn't
going to be to make organ donation
mandatory which would save many many
many lives
it's going to be to try to either
outright ban abortion at the federal
level
or undo gay marriage or something else
that will be horrible those will be
their next steps and we know it because
they told us that that would be it next
email is from john john wrote in about
the shooting in japan and says hey david
first time sending in a question love
the show here's the question could the
latest shooting in japan potentially
be stimulated by the united states or is
it only coincidence that this would
happen in the midst of heavy gun
controversy i don't know what the
shooter's reason was but i'm thinking
more motivation to action could we see
more shootings in places mostly
considered safe due to the us's
irresponsible actions towards gun
control which is inherently giving more
mass shooting examples as we know japan
gun violence is very rare so perhaps as
we see more shootings here it may
inspire shooters elsewhere lastly if
this were to happen could there
potentially be some point a third party
to interfere and tell us to get our guns
in check for example criticism in the
u.n would love your take thanks john so
the second part i don't know about the
question about the influence is a good
one now john isn't saying and i'm not
interpreting this to mean
is it possible someone in the u.s is
actually to blame for the shooting of a
former japanese prime minister shinzo
abe no the answer to that would be no
but the question of
has american gun culture
which has legitimized and mainstreamed
using firearms to solve problems
disagreements conflicts
could that be sort of leaking over
into other countries and the answer is
sure it could
sure it could i mean the united states
has a very
uh hegemonic culture in many ways
and that includes media of course
tv shows movies etc
to some degree also in literature and
books
so why couldn't it also be that hey look
in the united states there's this you
have a problem you have some
disagreement you go and you get a gun
and you and you solve it so as a
theoretical question i think the answer
is absolutely yes there were questions
as to whether the motivations and the
particular assassination of abe were
even political and i believe the shooter
said that they're not
but at least as a theoretical question
completely valid uh completely plausible
langdon wrote in about right wingers who
troll me
and langdon says hi david i've been
following you for quite some time now on
social media i joined rumble and troth
central about three to four months ago
i've noticed 90 or maybe more of the
comments or replies you get are from
right wing trollers i would love to get
your opinion as to why my personal
opinion is these people are so insecure
they feel the need to defend their right
wing beliefs when anyone challenges them
thank you i actually don't think that's
what it is i think it's much simpler the
reason that 90 or more of the replies to
my posts on rumble and truth social aka
truth central are attacks and trolling
is that those platforms are
overwhelmingly right-wingers their
right-wing platforms rumble less so and
rumble seems to more proactively want to
have more diverse content whereas truth
essential or truth social or whatever
you want to call it is more overtly
right-wing
the users are just on the right and so
they see my content and they troll me
and they attack me i think it's that
simple quite frankly langdon
david wrote in about cassie hutchinson
if hutchinson was so bad
why was she allowed to work for steve
scalise ted cruz and to be the chief
staff assistant to mark meadows wouldn't
she have been weeded out before january
6th how does she support herself now i
don't know how she supports herself now
but this is an endless question
trump ran on i will hire the best people
i might not have experience in foreign
policy or trade or whatever although he
claimed he was a genius in those areas
as well but his big thing was i will
hire the best people i hired the best
people to build my buildings and i'm
going to hire the best people that will
be my strength and then he hired all of
these different people who then quit or
he fired them and he said they were
terrible which of course calls into
question his bona fides as someone who
can hire the right people i'm talking
about
you know william barr and rex tillerson
and
john bolton all these people who as he
has since attacked well it sounds like
you weren't really that great at hiring
people and of course the same thing
applies to cassidy hutchinson's
testimony they insist now
disgruntled
not a very good employee not
particularly smart didn't really have
access to any of the things she claims
she can't be trusted terrible terrible
terrible
well she was not only hired but promoted
brought to the west wing to have a very
uh
close level of access to mark meadows
and sometimes donald trump
why if she was so horrible and
incompetent well because they're lying
because they're lying that's what they
say about everybody once they've fallen
out of their good graces
grant wrote in grant says looking for
your advice hey david my conservative
friends often bring up talking points
they don't fully understand but they're
convinced they have everything right
sounds like many people i know i
politely inform them when they're
incorrect but unfortunately i don't have
much skill at formulating arguments or
remembering facts when i refute their
claims but don't have the hard evidence
to immediately back it up they assume
i'm disagreeing just based on my
personal feelings
i'll be honest i don't have the deepest
understanding of government the economy
etc i never took any political economic
or history courses in college i'd like
to think i have a fair amount of common
sense and i'm an adequately logical
thinker but it's often not enough i'm
not a fan of confrontation i sometimes
crumple under the pressure when
dialoguing how can i better prepare for
these discussions okay so here's the
best thing you can do graham
this doesn't just apply to you
it is impossible to always be prepared
with the facts
on every issue it's it's just not
possible this happens to me as well the
most important thing you can do is
understand how people are thinking or
not thinking when they make these claims
and be prepared to probe how they came
to these conclusions
i don't know that much about i don't
know what's an example i don't know that
much about
uh
so many different things i don't know
that much about the ford versus chevy
debate right that's a debate i don't i
could not care less about it i remember
in high school there were the more uh
there was a contingent of kids in my
high school who were very big on ford
versus chevy and certainly american cars
are better than foreign cars okay i
didn't know a lot about it but my
instinct was that these were not
conclusions they were coming to from a
very evidence-based perspective so
without knowing a lot about the issue
there would be
very easy ways for me to say okay so
chevy's the good one ford's bad okay how
did you come to that conclusion
well uh i had a chevy and it lasted a
really long time oh okay that's
interesting and
how many chevys are out there well i
don't know
is it possible that it's millions yeah
it's possible so the fact that you had a
chevy and it lasted a long time does
that tell us a lot about all chevys well
no yeah i feel like it okay so you get
the point the the point is understand
and learn the socratic method of
questioning and how to probe people's
beliefs and you don't have to be nor is
it possible to be as prepared as you
might want on every issue
understand how to get people to realize
for themselves
that they may believe things not based
on good evidence
mice wrote in about a texting scam and
says i wrote a comment on youtube to
your story on liz cheney and i got a
reply saying send me a text with your
picture and a phone number is this real
it is not real so let me
we are playing a whack-a-mole with
scammers on all platforms instagram
youtube facebook everywhere
on youtube right now there are tons of
people who are using my face as their
profile picture and they're responding
to people and saying hey contact me via
whatsapp
i'll send you money i'll send you free
crypto i'll send you a free product if
you review or whatever okay i'm not
texting anybody i can't even respond to
emails that i get i'm just too busy so
i'm not texting with anybody in the
audience number one
number two
i'm not using whatsapp to contact
anybody
and number three
i'm not sending money to people in the
audience
if we did any kind of giveaway
i would talk about it on the show and
you would know it i'm not gonna be
silent on the show about a giveaway and
then reply to youtube comments one on
one okay so i'm not texting anybody i'm
not what zapping anybody don't fall for
report those accounts we're reporting
them as quickly as we can and uh
that's it i'm not don't don't respond to
any of it these are scams sean wrote in
about trump's presidential announcement
isn't it obvious right sean that trump
is announcing an early run because he
knows he's going to be indicted this
then gives him a loud speaker to claim
he's being arrested in charge because of
politics he will claim to be a political
prisoner i actually don't think so i
think trump has actually been delaying
announcing the presidential run in order
to not have the
reporting requirements for money that
comes in for as long as possible i i do
think there's a very good chance trump
announces a run and it'll probably be
i don't know maybe right before but
probably right after the midterms but i
don't think that the strategy is
announce really soon to try to mitigate
or in somehow influence
the potentially forthcoming indictments
i just don't think so if people disagree
with me just let me know and lastly
another perspective on trump's run allen
says sir i keep seeing trump might
announce a 2024 presidential run soon is
this something we should be hoping for
there is potential to split and ruin the
republican party for at least the next
couple of election cycles so there's two
sides to this
one that we've discussed is
what does it do for republicans for
trump to run
the other one we've discussed is was it
what does it do for trump for a lot of
republicans to run
i think that a lot of republicans
running
helps trump in the sense that if you get
all these two and three percent type
people maybe nikki haley maybe ted cruz
or whoever
that splits the more mainstream
republican electorate for a while while
trump just consolidates support so
that's more or less what happened in
2016. i think more candidates is good
for trump trump running i can't tell you
whether it's good or bad for the
republican party i think if trump runs
and loses to desantis for example it's
bad for the republican party it will
fracture it and that would be a really
great thing but some of this we won't
know until we see how do the midterms go
number one
and what level of approval does donald
trump have among the republican
electorate questions we we won't know
in the 2024 context until after the
november midterms but we'll of course be
talking about it and covering it we have
a fantastic bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpacman.com coupon code
big voting22 we will see you then or
i'll see you back here on monday